we've got a problem
a three-body problem okay sorry
I won't do that anymore anyway hello hi
people
how's it going how are you
how's your day
how's it happening
you guys been watching Everybody problem
you guys been enjoying this show because
it's been it's been pretty good
well kind of up and down you know a
little bit up and down
some highlights I think the last several
episodes have been pretty good pretty
much on the up and up
oh yeah we're gonna get to that
we're gonna get to that I'm gonna get to
all those things
uh yeah yeah so I went a little bit late
on the stream today
uh but you're now here we're gonna talk
about episodes 11 through 15 of
three body the tencent adaptation and
that's gonna be freaking awesome
so yeah
so yeah this is uh only our second time
streaming on the new channel
so we'll see how it goes
I think the audio should be working and
the video should be working can
everybody that's in the chat just please
let me know if the audio and video is
correct and everything sounds good
please let me know so that we can
continue
yeah I got some chatters
here
garlic Turtle uh I don't know
I don't know we're going to discuss all
that because I don't know a lot about
that actual situation so you got some
people in the comments discussing
one of the things that we've been
talking about for a little bit since the
show started which is that like certain
things
are a little bit different
in this show versus what I read in the
book I know that the
obviously
I don't know obviously this version is
the translated version so this is not
the original version the original
version the original version of this
book is in Chinese
so I've never read the original version
I don't know what it says but I do know
that certain things in the show
are different or omitted so far
versus this book right and um
we have seen
so far
quite a bit of yawinji's past but
there's one particular
moment that is still missing from the
show
and I don't know if it's going to be
included it kind of seems like they've
kind of gone past it
and changed it and that is yawinji's
father's death
now
in this book in this version of the book
in the very beginning
yahwinji's dad
is like tortured
and killed like beaten to death
you know by by like communist like
that's the whole thing and um and
they're like against science and they
don't and you know I mean it's like a
whole thing and it's at the beginning of
the book and it's super brutal and in
the show like we just see him kind of
like laying in the bed presumably dying
we don't see exactly like how exactly
what happens but it's really graphic
really brutal and just like really in
your face in the beginning of this book
and to me that is a pretty pretty sharp
turn
now so my Chinese fans let me know is
that scene in the in the Chinese version
of the book because it is in the
American version of the book and it's
not in the show so far so do we get to
see that later on
or not so that's my question to any
Chinese fans that might be watching
um because I don't know to me that's a
pretty important part of the character
right that's a pretty that's that's very
significant in my opinion and why yeah
wenji
so it is in the Chinese version book
it's just not in the show maybe or maybe
it's later in the show I don't know but
to me that's a very very very like
important part of like
what makes yahwinji become what she
becomes so like I'm watching the show so
far and I'm like
if they don't include that moment how do
they explain what she does later on and
by the way guys we're obviously full
spoilers on right now we're talking
spoilers for the show right now
just yeah so
um yeah we're gonna need we've already
seen we saw we saw the scene I think in
the beginning of the show where yeah
when she comes in and she's pressing the
button she's pressing the button but um
the job of the show at this point is to
get to
is to make us understand how she got to
that point where she feels like you know
Screw the rest of humanity right and I
don't know if the show has done that job
yet and I feel like if that scene is
completely omitted I don't know if it's
necessarily gonna work so we saw the
events with bye
you know and that's definitely part of
that's definitely part of
you know what makes yahwinji go down the
hole the rabbit hole of like
hatred for Humanity but that was only
like
that wasn't the first thing that wasn't
the initial thing that set it off
yeah they did yeah they showed yahwinji
getting betrayed by by they did show
that
and you know that was one point and in
fact I feel like in the book it even
says like
ultimately it's bias responsibility
maybe yeah Lindsay would have never done
what she did if it had been for buy but
that could just be because I don't know
if like uh logician was saying that
because it was like he was the Catalyst
for her getting sent to the red Coast or
if it was because like his actions like
changed her enough I don't think it was
that his actions like changed her
significantly enough where she's like
okay now I hate all of humanity because
of what bi did to me I feel like um
[Music]
um
what that's saying is that just that it
was his fault that she ultimately got
sent there you know
okay
okay interesting interesting interesting
so yeah yeah yeah so like
but so far what I what I have seen with
Yeah Wendy so far in this show though
like to just move move on from like
what's different from the book I do
think that so far this is some of the
best character
development character work in the show
that I've seen so far right
um I really enjoy the red Coast scenes I
think they're filmed very well
and it's also like just good to get away
from just like what the rest of the show
looks like it's like usually like
people sitting in a room together
talking so it's good to like jump to
something that looks a little different
and I also enjoy the way they portray
um the satellite um it's very like
mysterious and dark and creepy and like
I said in the last video I do like I
really enjoy the Trope of like the
mysterious laboratory like on the edge
of town I think it's really really cool
garlic Turtle says her sister still
snitched on her father yeah all that
happened
yeah we got to see
basically everything from the book
except for the most brutal moment and I
wonder why they cut that most brutal
Moment Like is that just like too much
for a Chinese Network or is it just I
don't know what the deal with that was I
don't know like I said in my last video
I am not Chinese I don't know a lot
about Chinese history or Chinese culture
really so I don't really have the
context to put all of this like in place
I just know that like what I read in the
book and the context that I was given in
the book like this is pretty significant
versus like in the show it's like
pretty altered if like the father is
like dying by his own hands or dying
like just laying in a bed like it looks
like in the show so
we will see anyway I thought um her
interactions with by what episode did
this happen and like I said the
episode's kind of bleeding this was
episode 11 right the the whole event
with uh bye
very similar to how it takes place in
the book where he has a copy of the
letter
and then he you know betrays her when he
gets caught
um yeah I thought it was very well done
very well acted the actress that plays
yawinji is excellent I really really
like the young yawinji actress the bi
actor was really good as well
um
yeah like just the scene where uh he's
throwing her on the bus the book
throwing scene
one probably the best active scene in
the show so far I think it was really
really well done you could really feel
the tension in the scene
um and even though I knew it was going
to happen because I read that scene in
the book is very similar in the book
um you still feel thrown for a loop when
you when you realize that bye she's
trying to you know not give him away
she's trying to protect him and the
moment when you realize that he's
actually
throwing you under the bus already it's
like such a like oh screw you dude it's
such a messed up moment and then you
know he has to
be really convincing with it and throw
in the book and essentially just like a
it's such a brutal
moment it's like man I thought we were
friends and you do this you go and do
this yeah so that that that that really
sucks and you think you like like
that character right you think you like
him and then it's like you go and do
something so like messed up like this
um but that's the thing I like about it
because it's
I think people in general are very very
complicated and I think yeah wenji
especially is a very complicated
character so um I think it's curious
because like when characters are
introduced to him stories I think we're
trained to see them in a very specific
way we're trying to like only look at
certain traits and think this is the
entire character this is the entire
person that people have
degrees
to them you know it's possible that you
know yeah Bae he's like he's this cool
journalist and you know he has all these
interesting thoughts and maybe yahwe
engine him
liked each other a little bit but it's
also true that you know he'll put his
own self-preservation over someone else
you know so yeah and that that that's
pretty lame I think the show and the
booktube does a pretty good job of this
but the show I don't know maybe it's
because the characters are visualized I
think the show does a pretty good job of
making us sympathize a lot with Yahweh
the character
um
because at this point in the story it's
like yeah I'm kind of like rooting for
him like everybody is kind of like
screw to Rover
and it's like it's at this point it's
like ah can she catch a break can she
catch a break
but like I said I don't know how far
um
I don't know how the characters percept
how I don't know how people watching the
show's perception of the character is
going to be affected by the fact that
they didn't show that
very brutal
um character development character
development moment with their father I
don't know how
um the perception of the character will
be affected like I said I have a
perspective of the character that's
informed by the book but I know there's
got to be lots of people that are
watching this show without reading the
book
so
I don't know about that but we'll see
ultimately how it plays out we got 16
episodes to go I got 16 episodes to go
on this
um so other than the yeah wenji thing
we've gotten so we've gotten up until
the point right before yahweinji starts
communicating with
spoiler spoiler the trisolare on so you
got we got we've gotten right up until
that point and then we've now gone back
into the show into like the three body
problem game and so we've now gotten to
in my opinion what is the most
interesting part
of the three body game so we finally got
acknowledgment I think this is the first
time in the show that we've heard this
we've finally got mentioned
of the three body problem we finally
we're finally talking about the three
body problem and like what it actually
is so Wang has figured out that there
are three different stars in the
trisolaran sky and that it's not just
about figuring out the rotation of one
of the Stars
or figuring out what's going on with um
just the sun you know I mean it's about
calculating the rotations of all three
Suns together which as some of you may
know is a very famous problem in physics
called the three body problem
now
um I'm really happy that we finally got
into this point by
um episode 15 and the other interesting
part that we get inside of the game
which was also a very interesting part
of the book we're going to get into a
little bit of spoilers too we're going
to talk about um just just we're going
to talk about Redemption of time just a
little bit the final book because I
think there's like a prediction that
that books book book makes well not
necessarily a prediction but as you know
Redemption of time is a spin-off novel
so there's like a little bit of
speculation being done uh on things that
shishanlu doesn't say
um but I think a lot of the things in
Redemption of time are laid out pretty
clearly in this first book and now like
being laid out pretty clearly in this
first season so what we know about this
game is that it's full of like it's got
the civilization that can they can
dehydrate themselves and their
environment is very unstable and like
they have to they're trying to figure
out like the cycles of their son so they
can figure out like when they come out
and when they go back into essentially
hibernation and now we've seen in the
most recent episode that this
civilization has the ability if the if
they choose to to act as a as a computer
as a super computer they can all come
together and act as a super computer
so the reason that this relates to
Redemption of time
this is
a spoiler right so if you don't want to
hear spoilers you should be watching
these reviews
so um
they keep
they keep mentioning the farmer
in the show like oh the farmer I think
it's pretty clear that the show is
pretty heavily implying the alien thing
they're pretty heavily implying it if
you're paying attention that we're
dealing with aliens here and they keep
saying oh this is the farmer's World
well yeah it is the farmer's world it is
the world of
try Solaris uh the alien group that ETO
is helping to subjugate Humanity
um and later in Redemption of time we
are given a little piece of information
that these aliens
are in fact tiny
so that book speculates because it is a
spin-off it's not officially but the
aliens are tiny so the aliens being tiny
explains a lot
right so it explains how they can
dehydrate that's not something that
large animals do
but a tiny little alien the size of a
grain of rice
can totally dehydrate so it explains how
they can dehydrate and then it explains
how they can
communicate with each other as um
how they can communicate as a super
computer because like very tiny
organisms
don't have huge brains but together
together they can do these immense
calculations
um and I think that's really really
really really cool to see and I noticed
throughout the show we also keep seeing
little ants showing up everywhere like
every every day someone every now and
again somebody will be looking at an ant
and I don't know what that's relating to
I don't know if that's indicating the
presence of a so fun or what but we do
get an ant scene at the beginning of
the Dark Forest and it's it's making a
metaphor for Cosmic civilization but I
think too the ant thing kind of just
represents the trisolarians in general
being
bucks so
um I thought that was
interesting it was very cool but anyway
it was very cool to see uh the super
computer thing happening I love stuff
like that I'm another one of my favorite
authors Adrian shakowsky does the thing
where we've got like an ant super
computer Colony I just think you know
the idea of computing is very
interesting because like you can make a
computer out of anything and that's
what's really funny about it we tend to
think of computers this you know like
boxes of circuits you know wires but you
know there's no reason that an organic
computer can exist Simon fish yes I can
see your conversation I can totally see
everything in the chat
mm-hmm
someone says the discussion share
between Wang and the general in the
beginning already set up the Alien
Invasion gig for me the impact is very
big on screen then on text
yeah I feel like if I had never read the
book and I was watching this show I
would already get
the fact that aliens exist someone says
what is your definition of tiny well in
Redemption of time the trisolarians are
described as the size of a grain of rice
so that is pretty tiny compared to you
know humans
someone says Tchaikovsky is like I don't
know too clever for the room like the
British Andy Weir don't like you overall
I don't know I tend to like Adrian
Tchaikovsky
um we're gonna be doing we're going to
be covering this book pretty soon on
Quinn's ideas doors of Eden
cryptozoology you know alternate
Evolution it's like really interesting
um
uh one and no have a season
Simon fish says wanna ask has Quinn
watched the animation Dark Forest I have
not watched the animation Dark Forest
because I heard it was very very bad and
a few people have said Quinn you're not
going to enjoy this so you probably
shouldn't watch it because it's gonna
just upset you
um like I said in my live stream Dark
Forest is my favorite book
in in the trilogy and I don't want to
watch a bad adaptation I just do not
like I'm just at this point in my life I
am sick of things that I love getting
adapted poorly I feel like we lucked out
as best as we could with doom I feel
like I'm happy that this show is you
know relatively close to this I mean
this show is closer to the book than
most and like I said
um
it's more it's better to I feel like add
things than cut a lot of things and I
don't think this show is cutting
a lot you know I don't think they're
cutting a lot
um it's just like some some things that
I think are a little bit touchy in China
um involving the cultural revolution and
Yahweh I mean yeah wenji's father's
death I think that's a little touchy so
I think that's being kind of like
cleaned up a little bit I did notice I
will say this I did notice that episode
can we talk about this episode 11
was about
10 to 15 minutes shorter than the other
episodes
does that indicate that something was
cut
does that indicate because I feel like
it's possible that they could have shown
a version of the of that scene
that we were talking about earlier in
episode 11 but they didn't
and it was only 30 minutes long I felt
like that was an indication that maybe
something was taken out of the episode
all right maybe you guys could let me
know what you think about that I'm not
sure but I just think that it's weird
that every other episode is 45 minutes
45 minutes 45 minutes 33 minutes
that's I feel like something was cut
um but I think it remains to be seen
you think China censor didn't they blur
out some text too I didn't notice if
they blurred out text or not and I don't
know who censored it
but yeah
someone said it said a lot of things the
judge scenes are cut out interesting
interesting I don't see like like I said
I don't know a lot about the culture so
I don't know exactly what the reasoning
behind that would be to cut things out
like that
um someone says they cleaned it up for
TV to make it PG-13 bashing ahead and
shooting a dead body isn't family
friendly friendly I absolutely
understand that that makes a lot of
sense because I don't feel like
something like that would be
shown on American TV either at least not
in
graphic detail unless it's on like one
of the premium networks I mean I'm maybe
like a FX or an AMC would do something
like that to an extent but it would
never be that graphic it would never be
graphic the way it's described in the
book because that's a really like brutal
scene in the book
um and actually even in the American
um translation and actually like before
that scene actually even starts it gives
you like a little blurb that just gives
a little context about
the revolution
okay it says here translator's note this
refers to the August
1967 editorial in the red flag magazine
an important source of propaganda during
the cultural revolution which advocated
for pulling out the handful of
counter-revolutionaries within the Army
many read the editorial as tactically
encouraging red guards to attack
military armories and seize weapons from
the pla further inflaming the local
Civil War waged by the Red Guard
factions so yeah um
and there's other little blurbs in here
throughout this chapter about
um the culture Revolution to give like
context but still like it's not a
history book so I don't have like all of
the information all of the contexts
around me yet but it's very interesting
and I hope to like kind of learn more
about it
as it goes on Simon fish says episode 89
are very boring some rumors says that
it's because something was cut well we
did mention this last time that um
couple of those episodes felt like
elongated like they were um just
reiterating things just for the sake of
reiterating things and to me I do find
that quite you know taxing even so I'm
just like I already know about this
don't tell it to me again
um but yeah there could be multiple uh
reasons that they're doing stuff like
that
hmm
yeah yeah
so let's see let's see what else is
going on in the game I will say one
thing that throws me off about the game
just a little bit
um and this honestly this is a little
bit confusing in the book as well I
think
um
because the game the game just is a
little bit weird the way it works right
so it seems to be there are
I don't know a certain amount of people
inside of the game
that are people playing the game and
then there's a certain amount of people
in the game that are just
generated by the game like most of the
people that like the people that are
dehydrated right that's not someone
that's just sitting in a VR suit
standing still doing nothing dehydrated
right that's just the computer generated
person right
um so I don't think it really like 100
percent is clear like which of these
people are actually humans that have on
a VR headset and which of these people
are just generated by the game uh it's a
little bit up in the air
and also some of the reactions to people
playing the game
um some of the reactions of people
playing the game is weird like I don't
understand like you're playing a video
game like you don't have to like scream
when someone is like about to throw you
in a fire it's like it's not actually
gonna burn you so it's like they're not
really portraying it like a video game
they're more portraying it like just an
animated sequence that's happening which
it's an artistic choice I feel like but
I feel like um I don't know I feel I
wish I wish that it looked more like a
video game than you know just uh you
know like a 3D animation type deal
that's just like a tiny little nitpick
not saying I don't like it it's like a
tiny little like if I was doing it I
would have like added I don't know maybe
like a little bit of user interface
because like the only user interface
that we see is like the fast forward
buttons
you know someone says I think they just
like to role play which is yeah knowing
Gamers that's a thing too yeah 100 but
um I wonder to what degree like how many
people in here are role-playing and how
I feel like some people are role-playing
and then some are in NPCs
that's that's that's generally where I
would think it's like a
yeah
so yeah the game and someone says the
game in the book seems to be a single
player with NPCs the TV show made it in
MMO I'm not exactly sure though I'm not
sure I'm not I'm still not sure if it
which is it I'm not sure
if I'm being honest
yes
yes Stefano there were definitely
players in the book
but I think there's also
NPC characters
I think there's also NPC characters in
the book because I don't think because
there's so many people there there's so
many like and we in the super computer
scene right how many people know about
this game
right there's not enough
someone says Nah the book was MMO
I don't know but how many people know
about this game for there to be like all
these humans just like on standby to put
on their VR headsets and to do the super
computer thing right that doesn't make a
lot of sense it doesn't make a lot of
sense at all
foreign
yeah I mean yeah I've been discussing
this with James as we've been watching
it because it's like okay so is this
character actually a person because some
characters will straight up say like oh
I'm this person and I'm like I'm playing
it's like obvious that they're playing a
character
yeah
yeah so it's a little bit ambiguous and
vague but you know does It ultimately
that part of it doesn't matter very much
like the game part of it doesn't matter
that very much
um I think at this point in the in the
show we're centering around the game but
like in these books it's really funny
like going back through this this the
storyline of the first book because I
probably mentioned this it's so far
removed from what happens
later on in the book like this is laying
just like the most subtle groundwork for
the events that play out later
um so yeah
foreign
okay someone says also Wang is the only
one who ever speeds up time yeah the
time the time speed up thing is
questionable right so if we have an MMO
how was the time speed thing possible
you know if there's a bunch of other
characters in here
does everybody just get to speed up time
um so the way
um we were thinking about it was that
maybe that there's different servers on
free body and that like I don't know
like maybe 10 or 15 people get like put
on a server and then the rest are NPCs
or something like that and there's
different servers that people go in and
out of perhaps
things
but yeah someone says the game section
in the book were some of my favorite
absolutely right just the I just trying
to solve the mystery of what's happening
and figure out what this place is and
what the game is depicting is absolutely
very very compelling
um and I really enjoyed those moments in
the show too uh like I said this this
last episode we really really got into
it uh and trying to figure out
and actually really getting into it and
like actually getting to
what's actually going on in the three
body problem Universe which is that it's
a tri-stellar
um
not try Stellar try Solaris try Solaris
try Solaris I don't know how do I say
that it's a try try solar star system is
what I'm trying to get to it's a
tri-solar star system it's the big thing
it was interesting in the earlier
episodes I forget which episode it was
maybe 12 or 13 where you have
a different model being introduced right
so there's a model where it's like
I forget exactly what exactly the model
was but that it was like the universe
has holes in it and there's light
shining through and that and then the
stars are just light shining from like
holes in the universe
um that the sun is just a big hole and
what's curious about that is I actually
think that's based off of a real like
um
School of thinking that actually existed
uh before Galileo people had all sorts
of
interesting and just like totally
made-up models about how the solar
system worked about how the universe
worked
um that's the thing about humans is that
when we don't know something we just
make anything out we'll just make
anything up and if it sounds good
everyone's just like oh I guess this is
true and it was curious to see this
played out like in the video game you
know
Stefan
um says Stefano says
how do you think they'll adopt the scene
taking place on trisilarious
okay so I think I mentioned this in the
first live stream that I did which is
that I don't know I feel like this is
this could be
we haven't given been given any
indication as to how they're going to do
it like
because in the book
that scene is written as if a human
wrote it like so they they've taken like
the trisolarin recounting of all these
events and they've like made it so that
it can fit within like a human
perception so it's almost like a human
is talking to you and it never really
describes what the trisolarians look
like at all but when it comes to a
television show how do you depict this
but what are what are the trisolarians
going to look like are we are we just
going to do
human beings that are like dressed up
and try solar just I don't know like
what is it gonna look like so I have no
idea
um so
foreign
garlic I think you're right that it'll
probably look similar to the game
yeah
because I think we've pretty much seen
the extent of like the CGI that they're
going to offer us and I've seen in the
trailer
um the boat scene from the end of the
show
from the end of the book and the boat
scene from what I can tell does not have
the best CGI it's not very good but yeah
yeah yeah
okay okay okay
Simon fish says each time the reporter
shows up I will skip without a doubt so
do my friends her acting is a disaster
um well
I just I think musing the character
losing is a bit out of place I do
um she seems to just to be there
I don't know to give I don't I don't
know I don't know why she's there
I really don't because she she'll pop up
and then she'll be questioning panhand
um she'll pop up and she'll be hanging
out with Dashi she'll be pop up and
she'll be messing around with uh Sean
you you fan I honestly think this is
gonna end with mozing
like if musing keeps sniffing around ETO
in the frontiers of science she's gonna
end up dead as a doorknob and I think
um that is that was the point of like
when she's like looking at her
windshield and we see the ant I think
the ant might represent that the
frontiers of science or that ETO is like
kind of on to you now I think that's
what the ants represents so I think it's
like ETA
knows what you're up to
Eto I mean ETO knows what you're up to
and they're not happy about it and so
now you're seeing this ant and I think
um in future episodes we might see
musing
um be influenced like Wang and uh
yangdong and the other scientists that
killed themselves because now she's like
inserted herself into the situation and
it's not going to end end good for her
so yeah but then again I don't know
because she's not in the book it's not
in the book
laughs
[Music]
um
someone says but her scenes are annoying
and I don't like when they waste OSHA's
time with interacting with her
yeah she's kind of a a random character
that like is just there this is one of
those things just there for no reason
like I get um I totally understand uh
making
uh what was her name Zoo being bing I
don't I totally understand Zoo bing bing
making her a bigger character because
she's around in the book and she doesn't
do much I mean she's around Dasha so
just yeah make her into a bigger
character
um but you know adding a whole another
character is weird
it's weird
but honestly I think I think she's axed
I think she's gonna get I think she's
gonna get it and it's gonna be like a
big moment for dasha so I think what
what they're doing is that Dasha kind of
likes her right I think that's what's
Happening Here
is that dashikan has a thing for her so
it'll be a big moment for dasha if she
is ultimately killed
you know it'll kind of maybe embolden
him even more against ETA sorry I keep
coughing like that air is really dry in
here
okay
I hate dry air it kills me
literally
Dasha is already married yeah I know but
still
[Music]
someone says this is not a romantic show
yeah but I feel like tonally the show's
like a little like kind of all over the
place
it's not it's not but I don't know I
don't know I just I just there's
something I read into maybe I'm reading
into it but something about dasha's
interactions with moo zing
like a little bit like it's
a flirtation happening maybe that's just
me
someone says actually there's a reporter
in the book but no more no more detail
just to nobody hahaha yeah so maybe they
just took a minor character and expanded
it that's a common thing in in
adaptations maybe not to this extent
usually when there's a minor character
they're not just gonna it's not gonna be
like this but yeah
Hecker says how do I watch this show
um the show is available on YouTube
um the episodes are free but I think the
free episodes come out a little bit
later than the episodes for people that
are members of the YouTube channel so
yeah
someone says I think it's just friendly
not flirty you guys could be right you
guys could be totally right and I'm just
reading into it so you know just reading
into it also also I said in the last
episode
in the last stream that I did that I
thought Dasha had a bomb on his chest I
don't know why I thought it was a bomb
but it was just a timer it was
definitely just a timer
still it's like it's I don't know it's
just kind of like weird
it's kind of weird it's kind of weird
someone says tencent seems to love its
mellow drama romances
um it does right um we watched a little
bit of choice husband because uh we just
wanted to see what it was
and yeah it's definitely one of those
just like super melodramatic romance
shows it's like it's pretty cute but
it's like you know choice husband
it's one of those
yeah definitely he needed it on his
chest for some reason
right why is it on your chest
James sauce's Choice husband is my jam
well Choice husband has a great opening
theme song right it sounds like a 90s r
b ballad but with some like you know
Chinese sounding instrumentation I dig
it I like it
yeah
someone says I love the scenes with JoJo
yeah um very cool that they uh I'm
pretty sure he has a son in the book
and the sun doesn't have very many
scenes
um so like he and I remember thinking
while reading the book what yeah yeah
this is this is one thing we can talk
about a difference that I kind of enjoy
a little bit right so I remember when I
read the book I thought that Wang didn't
very much care for his wife and his kid
that much I kind of thought like wow
he's really just kind of like
ignoring his family not just letting it
doesn't seem like
he likes his family that much or like
likes being around him that much in the
show you can tell he loves his daughter
a lot
um his wife him and his wife I feel like
have a better relationship in the show
than they do in the book and I like that
type of thing I feel like that's
appropriate um character expansion and
character development
um develop his relationship with his
daughter you know they even gave like
Dasha a scene with this with um
Wang's daughter but but I will say the
dash is seeing with Wang's daughter I
don't know if this is a cultural
difference
um but I don't believe that
um dodo had met
Dasher at the point where he picks her
up from school and I was always told
from a very young age growing up in the
United States that you never trust
someone that you've never met before
like especially in a situation like that
if like a man comes up to you at school
and he's like oh come with me and I'll
take you and get some ice cream I'll
like let you eat all the things that
your parents do I'll give you some candy
you know like I was taught if someone
walks with you and says that what you do
is run what you do is run as fast as
possible in the other direction
um so for me like watching that I was
like I don't know about that I don't
know
I don't know about that if she's never
seen him before
um that was like kind of crazy
someone says
I could be wrong but during the show's
intro credits I think there's an image
of try solara's current day I feel like
we've we've seen a couple of glimpses of
trisilarious in the show sometimes
they'll just show like a planet with
three sons or like three stars in the
distance just like little glimpses here
and there
foreign
little glimpses here and there
someone says LOL I was like what
happened to stranger danger at that
scene exactly right stranger danger
stranger danger
yeah yeah yeah don't don't don't you
kids don't don't go with like some
strange guy that picks you up from
school just don't do it
foreign
so that was weird to see but I'm but but
it's at the same time I'm glad that they
are developing that character more you
know because maybe yeah yeah
uh let's see let's see let's see what
else was interesting about the last five
episodes
like I said I feel like these episodes
were definitely like I feel like it
definitely got going for me like after
episode 10. like episode 11 to me was
just like
a banger like I feel like episode 11 was
just so good when we get the sequence
with yeah wenji
um and by and like him screwing her
screwing her over at the wood cutting
camp like that that episode was so good
great acting from the characters just so
the actress that's Place ya Wendy she's
phenomenal the young yawinji she's
phenomenal
um just
um because it's like it takes a lot
to be kind of
expressionless and then Express so much
emotion right because I feel like yeah
Wang yeah wenji the characters
definitely traumatized and she's kind of
like stilted emotionally a little bit
and you see she was kind of she was kind
of opening up to buy a little bit and
then in that last sequence you can just
see like where it like
everything just starts to close off and
it's like simultaneously her face is
blank
but her eyes are full of emotion and I
just thought that was real oh that was
really really good and then all the
scenes like in the secret lab like I I
enjoy it I enjoy it I also like to
I feel like I relate to Yao Angie a lot
because like I I wouldn't mind being at
the red Coast like if I was if I had the
option of like working like at The
Woodcutter place and being at the red
Coast working on the satellite doing
science experiments
I'd much rather be there
much rather be there it seems like
peaceful you get to go out and sit on
the mountain like look at and look out
at the trees every day that just seems
like
very nice honestly you know you're away
from everything you know it felt good
someone says like yeah I feel the pacing
picked up after episode 10. I agree
right I felt it felt like like we said
like spinning wheels for a few episodes
and then we got to episode 10 it was
like okay now we can now we can start
getting get go getting going and I think
it's definitely building and each
episode is hooking me more and more
um in the last episode I think ended in
a really interesting place where it's
like we're gonna see the results of this
super computer calculation within the
game
so that's going to be a lot of fun
um and to like the thing about the super
computer calculation within the game
that's really cool is that this is not
something that's
necessarily impossible I mean it's
definitely fictionalized to a to a
degree I mean I feel like the game
servers probably wouldn't be able to
handle all this realistically but
building a computer in a game is
something that's definitely possible
people have done it with games like
Minecraft before and other games as well
so it is possible to build a computer
within a game which is just like
so mind-blowing when you just think
about it for a second but yeah but the
thing about it is that like you're
you're using one computer to generate
another computer so it like if the
computer that you're using to generate
it isn't strong enough then it's
obviously not gonna work but you know
it's a whole it's a whole thing that's
the whole thing
someone says what is the budget for this
show will it resemble the expanse at all
in terms of money put into it no no I
definitely don't think so I don't think
this show is anywhere near as
um expensive as an American show and
this is something that I heard I'm not
sure if this is entirely true this could
just be like some weird rumor but I did
hear that
just one episode of the Netflix version
of three body problem cost 30 episodes
of this one so
um
yeah
so um this show is not I don't think
very expensive to produce I don't think
so
yeah so I we're looking the Netflix show
is gonna be like
huge budget type thing so this is just
think about it I don't know how much how
many of you guys watched Game of Thrones
right
um the Creator the creators behind the
Netflix show or the same creators that
did Game of Thrones this is their first
project since Game of Thrones
um I think three body problem in America
um it's popular among science fiction
fans Just Like A Song of Ice and Fire
was popular among fantasy fans but like
the greater
just in American General Life most
people I think don't know about it that
much you know what I mean but after Game
of Thrones came out A Song of Ice and
Fire blew up
blew up right
um and I think that David and Dan the
creators behind the shows are planning
the same thing with three body
um they're they've taken a property that
most Americans don't know about a
property that has some really stellar
and interesting Concepts that are very
unique
um and they wanted they want another hit
and will they get another hit that
remains to be seen but can they do this
you know as much as I don't like what
they did with the end of Game of Thrones
I I will say that as far as like people
that adapt Source material they do a
good job of adapting Source material
in general you know what I mean um I we
I haven't seen them adapt anything
science fiction but I will see I did see
you know the first several seasons of
Game of Thrones I saw all of Game of
Thrones but I saw the seasons when they
were actually adapting the book material
and you know they they made a lot of
good decisions they made some decisions
that weren't that great but they made
good decisions here and there as far as
like the choices they made and adapting
um I don't agree with everything but
they made some pretty good decisions I
think it could have been done a lot
worse so I don't like totally discount
it I don't think that I don't know if
the show is going to be terrible right
I'm not gonna I'm not just saying like
oh it's gonna be terrible because they
did it and I don't like the end of Game
of Thrones I'm definitely giving it a
chance and I know that these guys want
to redeem themselves in the eyes of just
everybody
so like maybe maybe they'll make a
banger show maybe like the three-body
problem Netflix
will be a banger
maybe it'll be good so um
so yeah we'll see we'll see or maybe
that's just me being very optimistic you
know maybe I'm just being overly
optimistic but yeah
someone says I hope Netflix wouldn't
ruin the show
yeah
but yeah like I'm saying um it is it's
David and Dan
um so
just the fact that it's them they're
gonna have budget right Game of Thrones
was one of the most expensive shows in
history right if not the most expensive
TV show in history uh one of the most to
watch TV show in history so Netflix is
giving them the budget like that there's
no question about it like that's the way
it works here at least when somebody
makes something that's like a giant hit
they get the budget no matter what like
they get the budget so um
that's no question there's no question
with that the question is how how is it
gonna like play out the question is like
what things are they going to change the
question is are they going to change
anything that fundamentally changes the
story and way it plays out and what it
means because that's when I start to get
pissed off at adaptations is when you
start to change the meaning of things
right so I feel like
mm-hmm
I would rather have an adaptation that's
you know
very very different
but thematically
resonates with the source material then
an adaptation that looks similar or that
follows the Beats of the narrative but
ultimately it like arrives at a
different point ultimately arrives at a
different message a different theme you
know I I I I would I would take the
difference same theme any day that's
what matters to me so if they can
if they can pull off that same feeling
and and create that same dredge
then then I'm all for it and I'm fine
with like enjoying two different
versions of the show I'm fine with it so
far uh this show has been
a mixed bag as well right I I think I
think there there are some episodes that
have been really good like some of the
recent episodes like I said and there
there have been some that are a little
bit boring and a little bit like drawn
out
but I think that we are moving on we are
we have moved into just as I think we've
moved into the second stage of the game
it seems as if we've moved into the
second stage of the show right so we
moved into the second stage of three
body and the other episode now we've
moved to the second stage of the show so
I feel like things are really starting
to take off you've got
Dasha right now is very suspicious of
yawinji and um that's good because you
know we know where it goes from here
right we know where it goes from here so
we've we the show is set yeah wenji up
so far to be a very sympathetic
character very sympathetic we will now
see from this point on how things unfold
and I'm very excited
and I'm very excited to see if tencent
chooses to pick up
the next book because you know I feel
like I I would love it I would love it
let's see
garlic Turtle says Netflix will just be
all westerners okay
this is something that I was thinking
about as well I really hope that that's
not true but God
see the thing the problem with
adaptations
is that a lot of times Americans will
take adaptations from other countries
and they'll totally americanize it it'll
take place in America but I feel like
with three body problem
the fact that it's in China is important
to the story and I would be really sad
if they totally take out the China
aspect of it they could make it work
potentially but oh my God if the main
characters
oh my God if the main characters are not
Chinese
it's it's gonna it's gonna upset me and
a lot of other people I think because I
don't like the idea of taking
something that's Chinese in origin and
just just just making the characters
white like please don't do that
um if if at the very least
if at the very least they're like um
chinese-american people you know what I
mean at the very least they should be
chinese-american like if we get if we if
we if if we see the trailer to the show
and we've got Samwell tarly from Game of
Thrones playing Wang and then Liam
Cunningham as Dasha I am not
watching it I am not watching it I I
won't support it at all so if they do
that
it will not be getting support from
Quinn's ideas absolutely not I
absolutely will not support the
whitewashing of three body problem
because for me like what is so
interesting about that book is is the
different cultural perspective well one
of the things that's very interesting
about the book is the different cultural
perspective it's not like like every
American Science Fiction that I've ever
read it's got a different feeling to it
it's got a different vibe sure Schindler
has different thoughts in his head
so yeah
this yeah yeah that's that's just my
opinion though I mean I some people
might not be that bothered by it you can
watch it I won't be
um by the way guys I think this is the
biggest stream that we've had so far on
this channel this is only the second
stream third stream right this is our
third stream here right this is our
second stream on this channel okay yeah
yeah so please hit the like button it
really helps out with the YouTube
algorithm and such uh thank you guys so
much for being here
all right so what else
Quinn they are shooting Modern Day
scenes in London John Bradley is a
protagonist most likely of the three
body problem well let's see if it sucks
it's Mystic but like let's uh
Samwell
this is my face
um
you know like if if David and Dan
totally whitewashed this show
when they're getting canceled
the Netflix version is not about the
second book there's no way Netflix
version that last second book no there's
no way
I feel like if if I'm gonna
if they actually do that and they
whitewash the show then when they're
getting canceled I'm gonna sit back like
this and just
I'm just gonna sit back and watch
because it's like you guys had you guys
had an opportunity to redeem yourself in
the eyes of you know sci-fi fantasy fans
you know you you messed up Game of
Thrones you know people who are getting
over it everyone's enjoying a house of
the Dragon they're moving on and now you
come in with you know this is this great
great sci-fi book
and you mess that up you're not going to
get another chance David and Dan you
mess it up you're not getting another
chance
so yeah yeah yeah
but I guess that all remains to be seen
I guess it all remains to be seen we'll
see what happens with the Netflix one
I'm not going to judge it I'm not going
to say anything about it we'll see I did
look at the ID and B I was just thinking
that like maybe like they haven't shown
maybe they just haven't announced all
the characters yet right I don't know I
maybe they haven't announced the actress
yet but uh I just don't want the story
to be like some totally different like
garbage
it's going to really really bother me if
it's bad and I'm really gonna let them
have it if it's bad right because
look for me like you guys know how much
I loved a song that I set a fire so if
they come in and ruin my other favorite
book
I'm gonna ruin my other favorite series
like you start off you ruin A Song of
Ice and Fire now you're ruining
everybody problem like you guys hate me
it's like whatever thing Quinn likes
let's go in and ruin it okay we're
getting preemptively
we're preemptively like getting mad so
let's not do that yeah
anyway back to 10 cent three body what
else what else what else
um
any more things you guys want to talk
about before we round things up with the
tense and three body problem review you
see the thing is garlic Turtle I know
it's going to be different from the book
so you know
Oh you mean the first six seasons of
Game of Thrones well yeah the first six
seasons I mean really
yeah I mean from the beginning things
are different I mean in in for instance
book two uh Daenerys is uh carth plot
line isn't entirely different utterly
changed completely
um
but it still works
to an extent and also their budget
wasn't totally there in season two so
that you can give them like a few breaks
in season two
but with this show it's like you got the
budget you got the source material the
books are finished you got everything
you need you've got all the context you
need there's nothing that you don't know
about what's going to happen
you need to be respectful to this Source
material and you need to not whitewash
the story and like God like can't God
guys
uh like you guys are you guys are you
guys are making me sad about this now
let's not do this anyway
10 cent free body enjoying it so far
episodes 11 through 15 I feel like we're
definitely better than the last block of
episodes that I watched uh we're gonna
watch episode 16 tonight hopefully
it gets to some good stuff involving the
game uh Quinn what do you think of yes
wife
um
and yang
what which characters are we talking
about
I don't know which characters you're
talking about
the death metal that says I'd say as a
writer I really don't care what people
want to do with my work in adaptation
interesting I don't know yeah I could
see that I mean as a fan of the story
that was a fan of like the book I do
care you know what I mean like as a fan
of the material I do care
someone says dude I'm still on episode
eight what's up AK
it's a shame you're just getting here
we're just about to wrap things up I
think we're just about to wrap things up
[Music]
oh someone says I think one of the
things that hasn't been in the TV
version as much has been the
environmental philosophy about around
the book they glazed over it um that
said the journalist plot covers that
stuff
oh yeah Wendy's mom
yeah what is it to I mean I don't know
I don't know what to think about yeah
Wendy's mom
anyway back to um Silent Spring
it is kind of glossed over a little bit
just a little bit in the show I mean it
is like that's a whole chapter in the
book right the Silent Spring part where
they're like really like telling you
like what is the deal with Silent Spring
so it is a little bit glossed over but
yeah
we'll see
anyway I think we have
gone over what we needed to go over
we'll be back like next week
in a few days to talk about the next
batch of episodes thanks everybody for
coming and joining me and watching this
is our most viewed stream on this
channel so far so thanks everybody hit
like on the stream I'm gonna get more
used to streaming I still like I gotta
continuously stream so that I can get
used to streaming because I feel like
I'm still totally not used to it I'm so
bad at reading the chat I'm like really
bad at like
you know talking and reading stuff at
the same time so if I ever like pause
for long periods of time that's why I'm
just kind of trying to like recompose
myself
and also like the thing about like being
on camera and speaking and like not
trying to sound stupid is like so hard
honestly like I'm a YouTuber but I hate
being on camera I really do I don't I do
not
I'm not like a uh I'm gonna be on camera
person it's not fun stuff not for me but
thank you guys so much please hit like
on the stream it really helps out
everything subscribe to this channel if
you're not already subscribed I love you
guys so much
um I think we'll come on here
at some point I don't know before the
next three body problem review and
review Avatar 2 because we did see
Avatar 2 in theater
and if
it was three hours uh it it was pretty
but you know we'll we'll get to it we'll
get to it anyway guys I love you guys
bye